welcome back to back to school season
we've got some gadgets that could help
make students return to the classroom a
little bit easier and our resident tech
guru cnet editorial director dan
ackerman and his team have tested
hundreds of products each year and he
joins us now with some of his favorites
hello there hey good to see you guys ken
has a different look toni
grant over here yeah with the support
cleanup i got a little cleanup and a big
time why did you get a cleanup why you
know i was looking a little rough i was
looking a little uh zz top-ish and uh i
figured i'd tighten it up for you guys
so this is the tightened up version this
is the tightened effort yeah that's good
to know you know what they used to be to
clarify um before we get into the tech
we've got some old-fashioned motivation
in a jar it's called coffee what do we
have here that's right well if you want
a big fancy coffee machine for your dorm
room they've got this ninja hot and cold
machine it does hot coffee it's got a
frother it does uh cold brew over like
10-15 minutes instead of like eight
hours that it normally takes for cold
brew but that's 200 bucks
if you want to go the other way this is
actually what i use now a simple chemex
uh pour over carafe about forty dollars
you just put your grounds in here you
drizzle your water on slowly that's the
pour over you get the fancy coffee shops
it's frankly the best cup of coffee i've
ever made and it's like forty dollars or
you can go all crazy and get the crazy
two hundred dollar one two i don't judge
all right talking about uh crazy
expenditures versus good stuff that's
cheaper we got laptops here that are not
macbooks that are good for kids so tell
me about it i still think that current
macbook air is probably the best overall
most universally laptop universally
useful laptop you can get but it's like
1200 now still great
most of the time you can get away with a
chromebook and there's some really cool
nice looking chromebooks out there now
this is the lenovo duet and it's an 11
inch chromebook it's got a touchscreen
you see it's got the keyboard but it's a
tablet too it just pops off like this i
love it you can just use this as a
standalone tablet pop it back in here
and it comes with the keyboard and
everything and it's shockingly like 379
dollars which to me seems like a really
good deal it does a lot of the things
that the the macbook does it doesn't
make you look cool that's the only thing
that yeah these are very cool my kids
have these yeah and if you're in school
you're using google classroom using
google drive using online tools and that
does anything that you need for that
keyboard is essential little kids big
backpacks that's what i associate with
elementary school this is a big backpack
well you need a big backpack now because
you got to protect your laptop and your
other gear so this is the up stockholm
from joyter it's a german brand and it's
got this super padded laptop sleeve
inside if you even stick your hand in
there i've got a macbook in there in the
padded sleeve a lot of laptop uh bag
makers make bags similar to this
but uh they're gonna drop it it does it
does look like something don't don't i
saw your hair
don't do that do not i think this one's
a little bit cooler looking than some of
the other ones but you can get away with
plenty of other designs as long as it
has that padded sleeve inside that's the
key okay
i was fascinated by a notebook you said
that never runs out of pages i'm just
curious about how interesting you know
you can take notes and scan them with
your phone a lot of different ways
this company called rocketbook actually
has these different size notebooks the
paper is slightly plasticky it has a
little coating on it
so you can write on it you scan it and
then it sends the information to your
google drive
but it also transcribes it so you get
the print version too you know it does
ocr
and then you take the cap off regular
pen but then you can wipe it with that
little damn cloth and all the writing is
going to disappear but you've got it all
saved on your phone and you send it to
your google play so when you write it on
this this is awesome you take your phone
you you scan it and then it shows up and
you're what's up but it transcribes it
and you get the muscle memory of
learning oh yeah yeah physically that's
why i still use a range yeah all the
time that's the only way i can remember
this is cool yeah that that's a winner
right how much is that do you know you
know these notebooks about 20 bucks 30
bucks a penny what's that
yes
with the pen you just get an app on your
phone and that's how you scan the page
it's a little qr code okay okay i was so
surprised by how much i like that i
thought i really liked hey but i was
like this is really good my christmas
present yeah yeah yeah
but but this is the this is the keeper
because kids always my kids especially
getting up in the morning super tough so
what what is this how is this different
from this is a lenovo smart clock i used
to use my phone as like an alarm clock
but what if you don't plug it in if it
doesn't work right it's a little risky
so now they have a lot of smart alarm
clocks this one works with google
assistant they also make amazon alexa
versions and you can swipe through and
get the weather and other things the
thing i like is that when the alarm goes
off you can just smack the top of it and
it's going to either turn the alarm off
or do the snooze mode depending on how
safe you feel setting up for one or the
other how about you take your pick and
instead of searching around the button
you just give it a tough tap on top and
that'll turn out what are you most
looking forward to about going back to
school dan i am most looking forward to
taking my son and sending him back right
exactly
good children in the house that he's 30
to 3 30. occupy
thank you